rockets are big
but no one seems to really know just how
big these rockets are
and that's because any time we're shown
these rockets they're always just kind
of like by themselves or flying through
the air or next to a big building or
even on a big boat you rarely get a good
opportunity to get some visual context
for how freaking big these rockets are
for instance the spacex falcon 9 rocket
is 230 feet tall
but what does that mean so today i'm
going to show you what you'll never get
to see in real life using visual effects
i'm going to put these rockets in
everyday places so that we can all gain
a better appreciation of the scale of
these giant bottles that fly into space
[Applause]
to begin let's take a look at the falcon
9 landing legs here and in pictures and
videos they seem kind of dinky like
maybe they're about this big or so
whereas in reality there are 29 feet in
length and when unfolded from the wall
they will reach out 24 feet and to put
that into perspective our ceiling is
only 17 feet tall these legs literally
do not fit in our studio and this begins
to give you a sense of scale so like i
said the falcon 9 rocket is 230 feet
tall meaning that it's about the height
of a 21 story building but the roof that
i'm standing on right now is only seven
stories tall that puts me about a third
of the way up the rocket
and it just keeps going up
and this isn't even the biggest rocket
that spacex makes they have a more
powerful one called the falcon heavy
which is basically just three falcon 9s
put together so it's the same height but
way more powerful so far they've only
had a single test flight famously
putting a tesla roadster out into the
asteroid belt to orbit the sun for the
next billion or so years and because
these rockets are so tall they appear to
be kind of thin but as usual when you
start getting closer to them their size
becomes apparent because they are 12
feet in diameter i could literally stand
on top of myself and still fit on the
inside of one of these rockets but
here's the thing spacex is developing a
much much larger rocket because they
need something that can go really far
into space but also carry a lot of
weight while they're doing it like to
mars like a colony to mars
so that's what they're making next the
bfr which stands for big falcon rocket
because it's really falcon big at
348 feet tall the bfr is taller than the
statue of liberty even if you were to
lay the falcon heavy sideways on top of
the statue it still wouldn't be as tall
as the bfr this rocket is truly massive
with a 30 foot diameter it's as wide as
a london bus is long i mean just look at
the fuel tank that's going to sit in the
upper spaceship part of the rocket as of
mid-2018 this rocket doesn't technically
exist yet except for the drawing board
and ncg renderings like this but this is
it this is what it's going to look like
in fact i believe they want to get this
up and flying within three years maybe
six years definitely and as big as these
rockets are we may someday see rockets
that are even larger i mean the bfr is
still not as large as the saturn v
rocket which took us to the moon and we
built that 50 years ago in the end i
just find it crazy that these structures
are some of the fastest vehicles
humanity has ever made because going
into space is not just simply a matter
of going up it's a matter of going up
and then sideways so fast that you just
continue to fall around the earth and
those speeds are 17 000 miles an hour at
sea level that is mach 22.
thanks for watching this video it was a
pretty fun experiment to make and if you
liked it i think i might try making more
of these in the meantime try sharing
this video with your friends and asking
them first how big that they think
rockets are because i'm willing to bet
they're gonna underestimate it if you're
new here try subscribing to the corridor
crew we got all kinds of crazy cool
content coming your way from diy builds
to cool science experiments like this to
the old school behind the scenes content
that you've always loved and enjoyed